i mean i i tell people
you know at least analogously
there's no really rhyme or reason when a
commissioner walks out to hand out the
trophy or the mvp where they're booed
by the fans you know and like
you know one of the i think probably the
most long-standing television show at
least in in the us and successful by
many accounts is the office which taps
into
the psychology of us as people to hate
your boss or like when you're in the
workplace understanding division of
authority and
i think that lives in sports like
players are drafted and they're like all
right it's us versus the owners or you
know i'm my gm who's deciding on my wage
is my enemy and
uh what we got from giving players
shares in the business was like hey
we're in this together
and when we have brand partners come in
and they're doing
uh content shoots on the grounds of game
weekends like our players are much more
willing and excited to be a part of it
because they know that as the company
grows then their value creation grows
too
uh and that was our bet because we knew
like it's really really competitive out
there you know it wasn't about beating
major league lacrosse which was the
original
league it was about getting to a place
where we're summer sport we're competing
with mls and we're competing with you
know the nba and the nhl when they're
finishing up in june and like how do we
take a slice of those revenues from
television contracts to sponsorship and
um you know the good news is they
continue to grow
and and create a bigger pie and we're
just trying to you know participate in
it as well
the fact that it came that it started
officially in 2019 like you probably in
last year were going oh
[ __ ]
like
i i'm did you how did it what happened
like what
i mean obviously
i feel like you probably feel like it's
starting this year almost just with the
way that it went
um i mean
i'm just thinking content content
content you may be filmed extra personal
content but like for stuff on the field
and getting in the monks with the fans
and you know i know that it's also a not
a city-based sport in that the whole
league
goes around together correct that's
right
so
um but just getting to the fans in
general i mean
[ __ ] right what happened i mean if if
when mike and i were on the fundraising
trail in 2017
if we had a crystal ball that said we
would hit be hit with this global
pandemic in 2020 we'd be like no we're
not doing this and our investment we
wouldn't be able to raise money either
it was yeah it was hell
and we're still like meeting with our
kobe committee on a weekly basis and our
co leads that process and you have
different variants now and it's it's
just
do you you know what i always have to
say this because watching sports and i
love all sports so um but when i watch
sports and maybe i'm gonna get in
trouble for this but i don't really care
um
there must be so much like pomp and
circumstance just like
doing what is politically correct versus
what is actually sensical because when i
watch like basketball just ended
recently but but watching them be on the
side with their masks sitting next to
each other and then being on the court
together and you know i mean you just
watch that and you're like this is not
sensical it's ridiculous and this is all
for appearance purposes
like you must be over the [ __ ] of
what it takes to just like play the
sport yeah
it is super complicated it goes back to
that
public and private profile that we have
to have as a business
very few companies have to juggle that
but the reality is when we're
casted on nbc owned and operated
broadcast and cable and peacock and same
thing with the nba through turner and
espn
is like you just have people watching
you and
um and you have to
uh demonstrate code
because if you don't the flip side is is
you can get crushed especially if
there's a slip
and i agree on like the nonsensical
stuff can be a little bit inane it can
feel a name where like guys are wearing
their masks on the sideline and then
they're like on the floor and they take
their mask off and you're just like well
i don't get it yeah it kind of reminds
me of the school system from time to
time like you have to
you have to educate you have to get in
line you have to do things certain ways
uh to make sure that
at least like the boxes are checked the
other piece is for us as a league
we actually take it out of our hands as
as operators and so we brought on an
external coveted medical committee that
makes decisions and that way like we
have the professionals doing it and we
adhere to their policies and uh that's
that's super important and it's at least
you don't make the decisions because you
know that is always a political disaster
and also then say there's a slip up
right or something happens it's it's
it's why in sports and maybe you can
share your own perspectives of this or
or how how you operate or perhaps even
the arc that you've had as an athlete
getting to where you are and being like
one of the best of that's ever played
versus when you were younger is that
there's so much stuff i can this is from
my perspective that you do early on
because you just can't give someone a
reason
yeah and then later on you just go you
know what and and then of course you
know this is not applying this is not
the same thing for you know protocols
and things like that but it's out of
your hands and then you don't have to
worry about being judged for it where
you know as an athlete you just make
sure that you do everything possible
that no one can go that's why
yeah yeah for sure and that's that's
part of our our job as entertainers and
i remember peter gruber telling me that
early on when i was
pitching him on investing in the league
and he didn't
um but he grew up playing lacrosse and
and does think
uh highly of of what we're creating
but he had said a couple of things when
i was like kind of pitching our media
strategy
he was like sports is not entertainment
he's like sports is show business like
this is this is full-on show business
the business you're getting into
and the other thing he was like can we
figure out how to play lacrosse without
helmets which is a whole nother
conversation unlikely because the the
ball is so dense and there's concussion
fears and all this other stuff but he
but his point around show business is if
you think about athletes who are
personified globally a lot of them is
non-helmet sports unless you're a
quarterback
and quarterbacks you know were honestly
they were crop that tried to unionize
before the nfl pa it was the
quarterbacks club and and yeah there is
like a dynamic
uh between quarterbacks and and other
skill players because they just are the
most well known they're in the press
conferences the most they have the ball
in their hands the most when people know
what their face looks like helmet sports
is difficult soccer basketball i know
what you mean
exactly there you go i mean if it
weren't for the media outside of the car
if it wasn't for the interviews if it
wasn't for the talk shows if it wasn't
for you know my version of the the
production my version of the
content content content um people
wouldn't know me either